en esta explosiva y sin precedentes
comparecencia de siete horas en el
parlamento dominica mens aseguró que por
la incompetencia del gobierno miles de
personas murieron por ccoo y 19 que no
tendrían que haber muerto afirmó que la
estrategia inicial del gobierno fue
dejar avanzar el virus hasta que se
alcanzara la inmunidad del rebaño que
inicialmente boris johnson dijo que ésta
era apenas una gripa y que pensó incluso
en hacerse inyectar el virus en
televisión para así demostrar lo que la
prioridad ha sido siempre proteger la
economía que los confinamientos aquí en
inglaterra se han decretado muy tarde y
que incluso boris johnson no es la
persona adecuada para ser primer
ministro británico pero dominica mens
fue especialmente duro letal podría
decirse con el secretario de salud más
hancock de quien dijo tuvo que haber
sido despedido del gobierno hace rato
por al menos 20 asuntos y especialmente
por mentirle al público aunque es la
mini camins abrió las puertas del tras
escena de los primeros días caóticos de
la pandemia aquí
el reino unido- la investigación formal
e independiente sobre el manejo de la
crisis que ha traído el kobe 19 al reino
unido- sólo iniciará en la primavera de
2022 pero estas declaraciones
seguramente serán un gran insumo